ain't no competition in the ring
decipher cause i'm spitting finally
swinging fire talking pickle peppers
make em pay the piper cause i might go
look like a rude discussion and deflate
your chest like a food production you'll
be talking like you want a new
concussion can i do the custom attitude
adjustment
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve for another
knuckle sandwich i will serve heaven's
tipping moving like a tire swerve out
here acting bad thank you michael
jackson even got his one and only homie
captain you were phony homie now you owe
me action have him sinking tony tony
tony braxton and they all want to talk
for attention but the fame only lasts
for an instant mama got hands so i'm
ready for the tension i'ma leave him red
you could dance
[Music]
welcome back to another exciting episode
of comeback talk with the king what's
going on people
i'm out here with the love
let's get this poppin
what's going on let me see how many
people we got out there we got six
people watching that's what's up
um
first of all what you're sipping on what
you sipping on
everybody hit me hit me if you can hear
me hit me if you can hear me
put a thumbs up in the chat
all right let me see
so cinco de mayo
everybody knows the cinco de mayo
that's the ice
oh did it go pogie
pineapple express let's get it going
bang bang
but um
i thought we start off
with you know a little favorite little
favorite
for cinco de mayo
let's get our uh
hispanic people and uh your people of
hispanic descent
cheers
cinco de
mayo now this is how you make a sunrise
right
you pull that
that um and they're not sponsoring me so
boom
then you get that a dash of orange juice
and i don't have my trademark
what's going to call it i don't have my
trademark straw
so i know my wife is watching and she
like oh
he don't got a straw
and then you pour a dash of your special
that's it
so right now um
we're at grayson versus gomez right now
it's in the 10th round that's almost up
then we got the um
the frenchie extraordinaire
i love the fact that he has his french
and he takes his friendship with him
everywhere he goes
oh my god
gomez is down in the last round
uh he does he looks worse for where
race off is about to close the show on
him
uh left hook
he's stalking him
it's two minutes left in the round
gave him a nice little body shot pushing
him up against the ropes
uh straight right hand then he gave a
hook
nice jabs nice jabs
from grayson gomez is you know he's
still not backing down he's there he's
there to fight he's throwing jabs and
right hands
but he should not actually actually she
should hold but gomez has that fighter
spirit is the tough round he's selling
her all out he's giving everything to it
oh he throws a right hand and catch this
ghost off over the head
this is definitely what's up
all right so they're in the center of
the ring right now
this stuff is jabbing them to the body
gomez has a high guard
shoots a
straight jab to his head
and you know
uh
gomez doesn't look any worse for weird
to be honest with you gomez is actually
backing up gustav
and he's shooting a hard jab at him
and he's throwing the right hand over
the top so he's throwing the one too his
head is clear oh man
gomez is out here trying to really
actually win this fight in the last
round and he actually has gustav on his
heels
after being knocked down
some guys need to get hit they get woke
up and uh obviously gomez is that dude
we have a minute
left
good nice jab stay in the center of the
ring i thought the fight would have been
over actually
what's going on
hustle what's going on baby i want to
give a shout out to everybody who said
definitely poochie for definitely being
the first one here what up imax what's
going on baby
didn't order the fight here for the
commentary
that's what's up
what's going on we back baby that's
right turn the [ __ ] out what's going on
baby
we back at it 12 seconds left in the
10th round
and gomez is actually on the hunt i
think uh gustav actually just uh
you know just want to win the fight on
um
on the card to be honest with you
but
that was a good that was a good ending
of the round
i actually just pulled up right now to
be honest with you i'll let the
undercards rock and um getting into the
main undercards we probably have like an
hour to go before we get to canelo so
which is happy everybody
cinco de mayo weekend
we have a great fight coming up
a lot of you guys don't know who bible
is
um
bible is the light heavyweight champion
uh he is
he's he's really decent
he just has a couple of glaring uh flaws
that i see
that i think canelo can exploit and if
canelo can exploit these these flaws
from bibble
then it can be
a ninth round tenth round type of
knockout
um
excuse me
but if bevel
actually does what he does best and um
keeps him at distance if if
canelo starts slow and let devil get
into his groove
it could be a long night for canelo be
honest with you
let me see
yeah but gomez ate that
yeah he definitely did he definitely did
everybody who ordered the fight and was
watching the fight along with me
putting one in the chat
if you're just listening
you know you're just supporting you just
want to hear it excuse me
put a two in the chat
yo the zone
is is one of the the best crooks in the
world now remember when they they gassed
us up to purchase
the zone
and um it was like a hundred dollars for
the year they say oh all these fights
will be free
then all of a sudden now
we are paying for pay-per-view
they just throw that in there like oh
okay here's a pay-per-view
but don't i pay for the streaming
service i thought i was supposed to get
all these fights for free
it's a hustle
he said canelo is the only fighter that
you know in the car
um
watch
okay so they have to death to score
cards right now
so um
you have gomez that's on the right side
in the corner
and you have uh
gustav that's on
the
left side
[Music]
yeah
so
he won got he scored the knockdown in
the in the last round i get didn't get a
chance to see the whole fight to be
honest with you uh but uh he definitely
put in the work at the end and he held
on enough to
make sure that he didn't get dropped or
lose that round
because gomez was definitely coming for
him
yeah showtime is the same crooks 100
percent
oh thank you what's up rob
thank you roberts that's what's up
jonathan
everybody everybody here get in grouping
come on in man come on in have your
drinks sit down put your feet up
be a whole group chat we all out here
watching the fight talking about the
fight and if you ain't seeing the fight
you can just listen to me tell you about
the fight
the the the what is the the professional
fan
yeah
king david the professional fan
i ain't gonna front man gomez look like
he's in hell of shape yo speaking about
shape y'all seeing canelo at the
weigh-in
hmm
boy looking kind of soft around the
middle
chest looking soft
um
oh so gustav got dropped in the seventh
and he got back up
he got dropped again
ah so he he got dropped a couple of
times in this fight
man
canelo body did
i'm listen if he took this guy as a joke
if he if he took
bevel as uh
his name was dimitri bibble if um
he doesn't respect exactly what bible
brings to the table
this could be a long night for canelo to
be honest with you
i see
canelo if if
if he doesn't because you know biver has
a snap on his right hand if bibble can
set up his jab and his right hand down
the pipe
boom he can definitely hit canelo and
but see he he boxes with an open guard
so and the open guard is designed to
bring in the attackers right and what
happens is the um he's a boxer counter
puncher so
the the counter puncher in him he's
supposed to take over from that point on
and he's supposed to jab and you know
deter you suppose is it's all about
timing counter punching and pot shotting
and that's how bibb will fight but
bibble leans too much on his on his back
leg on his uh his foundation leg
and i don't like how that leg looks when
he's fighting
all right so we have uh two more fights
before the main event all right so we
have montana love that's next
montana love
i love montana love because he comes
with a french bulldog and his french
bulldog is the mascot and it's so dope
let's see
jonathan robinson
king he's to go thank you what's up man
yo
i got to give you a shout out to my left
nut is itchy
that's wild crazy
oh
that's you that's for you that's crazy
uh
late for dinner yo yo yo what up what up
don't fall for that king about the way
he looks the same we call no he didn't
look the same with kovalev should i
with with with kovalov and if you go
back to the pictures he looked like he
was in shape
um trust me when i'm telling you his
arms look smaller
um i don't know what regimen they had
him on as far as um
uh the testing goals i don't know if
there was regularly testing him and
stuff like that because that plays a
heavy part in in what's going on to be
honest with you so
personally
if canelo wasn't able to
train how he normally trains
work out how he normally works out or if
he wasn't as focused as he should be
in this fight
um i honestly believe that we could be
in for a 12 round decision split
decision that goes the way a bible
because bible is definitely a guy that
can that can last and it can get to 12
rounds i mean he's a champion right so
what are we expecting here what are we
expecting to see out of this fight we're
expecting to see canelo going in and
give 110
um
this mexican pride weekend he's
definitely on and the cinco de mayo he's
on his job he should be on his job
but you know you got bevel fighting for
a whole different reason so
let's see man
he said paul's on that name yeah for
real man
he out here son you can't front
you can't freak out
nothing wrong with your name man you
just ain't gonna get me to say it no
more you good though
you put that that that bait trap name
there that people gotta
all right what up frank k
all right there's no membership but i
paid for the fight yo listen
late for dinner i have
the same the zone membership
and
i mean we should just it should be uh
outcry more but nobody's gonna hear the
little guy screaming right because we
still want to see the fight it's not
like they're not going to put it on
pay-per-view to pay canelo they got to
pick canelo
he won them there so you know eddie
hearn got a pam and it wasn't working
out in that format um because they was
losing money i know they was they that's
why they raised the prices
this is my last year on the zone anyway
because eddie doesn't have uh enough
fighters you know he didn't go out and
get crawford he's trying to steal tank
um
he couldn't get earl
uh
he's trying to get adrian broner but
adrian broner wanted too much money
so it's it's it's a lot of series of
events that um eddie hearn couldn't
overcome he started losing his fighters
uh he just lost their devin haney the
top rank for at least three fights and
those are the three most important
fights that devin haney is gonna have
so you have to ask yourself really
what does eddie hearn have to offer
so after this year i mean i'm out unless
unless something major happens unless he
secures the tank fight but then if he
does secure the tank fight it doesn't
matter
because it won't be on the zone regular
it will be on the zone pay-per-view
right
so nah they're not going to jerk us
around remember
not only cinco de mayo but he need to
fight triple g in september yup to
finish the trilogy and i'm a feeling he
needs to
uh finish flashing uh internal should
die
he has okay so he signed this deal to
fight bible to get this belt and then to
fight a triple g
for triple g's belt
all right so
uh canelo right now is warming up uh in
the back um
[Music]
he has a shirt on so i can't tell you
what he looks like now after he
hydrated um
he he looks he looks normal he's
sponsored by dolce gabbana
is he sleeping on satin sheets
is the gucci flip-flops is uh or are
they taking over
is he the same hungry canelo that we
know there goes sean porter
sean porter is the happiest dude in the
world
at being retired um
i i listen
i think that that last fight that he had
with bud i think that was a gimme man be
honest with you i i
you know i don't have anything wrong
with but i just want to see bud fight
the same level of competition you got
earl spence coming to the table with
three belts right
he's coming with the waba
uh
wbc and ibf belt
bug coming with the wbo
that he got on the humble
and and i'm just saying like he didn't
fight the keith thurman he didn't fight
the danny garcia
and
those fights was presented to him they
were offered to him
but bud is sitting around waiting for
earl spence to clean up all the belts
and then
you know he get the good payday
i don't know man i don't i don't i i
seen it on the outside looking at it and
then remember sean porter was his buddy
i don't know man it smells that one
smells fishy to me man i really expected
uh bud to get up there and fight some
good competition amir khan
and kell brook is not great competition
to be honest with you so
i'm just saying
what everybody playing tonight what was
y'all playing earlier because i
i i
finally beat that three-headed dragon in
elder ring
and boy oh boy if yo
i have one speck of energy on him right
i thought i beat him i threw my hands in
the air walked away i was like yes yes
he threw fire and killed me i was mad as
hell
hollywood drugs what's going on king mom
with the 5 super chat king my man love
the ilp weekends keep up the great work
brother definitely 100 every saturday we
ought to accept
except for the saturday of what is it
memorial weekend memorial weekend uh the
king will definitely be out of the
building
but hopefully
it's not that great fight because we got
a great fight next weekend
next weekend we have jamal jamal jamel
charlo
versus us castano too
man i watched the first fight at least
10 times to get a bead on it and to be
honest with you
i walked away from that fight as it had
to be a draw
what's on hassan tyrell what's going on
last man standing what's going on all
right
respect to sean porter he is the nicest
guy
it doesn't matter about his losses his
fight style is attractive
crawford thing is his fault this is
being with top rank yeah but he's not
with top rank right now
eternally you already know that he's a
free agent right now and he was shopping
himself and he almost went with the mtk
until they found out allegedly about the
owner about that and you know with the
mob ties and stuff allegedly
right so you know stuff like that i
think um i forgot her name i think she
is the most gorgeous female boxer today
um her skills
is
she she's good
um i think she needs a little bit more
um seasoning when it comes to
actually her defense and stuff but as
soon as soon as i see her name again uh
i'll remind you my wife watches us
and stuff like that um the two uh women
that fought last week um
kate katie and serrano
boy
see i like i like defense and offense i
just don't like sloppy fighting so they
had some defense and some offense and it
was tight in the in in their combat so i
can't really get on them too much
but it was it was one of the the better
um female fights that i've seen in a
while it was really good
let me
action rpg omar that's what's up
yeah
tomorrow's mother's day
i hope i hope y'all went out and got
your mothers whatever they needed your
significant others whatever you you
expect them to have um
you know i hope y'all did that stuff
i i i did a couple of things so
hopefully i'm good i'll be good for a
little bit hopefully hopefully
so this is called a sunrise
you uh
take uh
your favorite little mexican drink right
spanish drink and then you you know add
ice throw that in there then you throw
a little bit
of orange juice inside splash arms just
and then you throw a splash of
your uh
special
uh sweet beverage that you want to put
in there mine is you know so rock citrus
through that up in there bam and then
you get that sunrise look see sunrise
everybody sit back have a nice little
sunrise
yes that's right that's right we're on
everything
[Music]
crawford the money that they was
offering crawford was too good for him
uh
not to leave top rank and remember he
was fighting bums well i'm not going to
say buns he's fighting high level b
characters
108 dragons with the 5 hour super chat
that's my dude
your brother in the building
canelo stand up
yeah
some people might be disappointed
tonight i don't know man um as the fight
gets closer i'ma see exactly not
yo i'm available messing with you i'm
just messing with you lemon
holy crap mom's day i almost forgot
thanks
yo
you better not you better yo you better
not jiggy j what's good my dude
um you better not forget mother's day
i don't care you better call your moms
you better do whatever you gonna do
you better not forget mother's day don't
play that game man don't act like you
playing this game
all right so we got montana love coming
to the ring well not right now
uh ahead of him is his opponent i'll
give you his name but i just really like
montana love to be honest with you i
think that frenchie because you know i
got that frenchie love i love french
bulldogs i think french bulldogs is
so much fun i think they are
humans
putting furry little forms and they may
they just like hilarious they like
comedians i think if um
if dave chappelle uh was ever
resurrected he came and he come back
he's gonna come back as a french bulldog
think the same thing cat williams kevin
hart every comedian is gonna come back
as a french bulldog
and um hopefully when i retire i get to
have a frenchie for him and i get to
have all of him
[Music]
he looks scared to death
he looks absolutely terrified that check
must be good
run away dragons tv with the 5 stupid
chat super chat he's just a stupid chat
right freudian slip my dude
he said laugh out loud you stupid hot
guys for the bushes
yo the story of high guys
is crazy as hell shout out to the 63
watching yo hit that like button please
support her brother it's funny as hell
all right if if i can get if i can get
50 thumbs up 50 likes i'll tell a story
about hi guys
and hi guys i swear you will pee on
yourself with high guys hi guys will
make you pee on yourself
hollywood rules what's going on with the
2 super chat king what's up with the
esports boxing game
i thought i was going to see that at pax
right and um here come love right now he
got a rapper uh coming out with with his
french bulldog he got us all yo he's a
showman i love this dude
he's funny as hell man i'm telling you
if you're watching a fight right now
montana love is coming out you gotta
google his interest
it's dope anytime you can walk out with
a french bulldog so my friends bulldogs
are crazy they they be trying to bite
people
but i thought i was gonna see that
esports boxing game when i went to pax
and i wound up seeing a um
excuse me boxing manager 2
and we did the the interview for boxing
manager 2. uh shout out to sovereign we
did that it it boxing manager 2 gives
you all aspects of fighting right um but
without actually getting in there and
mixing it up so um
that's that's it's it's it's an acquired
taste to be honest with you
uh the esports though i think i'm gonna
have to pull some strings to actually
get a background and go check that shout
out to my boy hip hop gamer might have
to be calling you on you we got 99
people in the chat if we could get it to
50 likes imma tell you the story about
hi guys
and i guarantee you you're going to pee
on yourself we got 119 people in the
chat
if you get the likes up
to 50 i'm going to tell you the story of
hi guys
and i guarantee you you pee on yourself
i guarantee you it's ridiculous
but
um it's funny i'm telling you
let me see
man hit that like button i'm trying to
crack up i feel you
you know the world for fights was
rinsing repeat fighters
yes seven times bradley eight times jeff
horn yeah yeah yeah
it's the same thing yeah you know what
i'm honored to be honest with you
internal that's exactly how i felt with
crawford i thought his uh the fights
that he was having was uh retreads and
stuff uh not breaking ground on any you
know new up-and-coming dope fighters
like that
so it is what it is
okay
so to get restart right now
and it's about to get crazy
i can't he look like a rob singer
but he does have some decent skill i
can't lie man all right so we got 33
people i mean 33 likes up there come on
let's get the rest of those likes in
there we got 68 people in the chat we
had a spike just then they probably
thought that it was uh
the fight started but it didn't start
yet
it's about to it's about to
[Laughter]
this looks good this looks like it's
gonna be really decent so we have uh
love versus gonzales
gone less
i don't know
i don't know what his nationality is
but you look like he ready to get busy
oh yeah 20 weeks i love 20 weeks as a
referee tony weeks is a referee he
doesn't get too much in the way
separates people here and there it's
pretty decent
so let's go
so you know what it is
probably
um
they had to make a deal with uh some of
the stable mates from
bible stable to get some of his fighters
onto the card and that's something
that's commonplace on cards when you
have them the headliner they can
actually pull in some of their friends
and stuff like that on the card to fill
up the card so it works like that
[Music]
there you go you got some people out
there in the crowd phone
all right
here we go
[Music]
here we go montana love
last time i seen him he knocked the dude
out in the first round
buck wild right hand
all right so montana loves 17 and no
oh
one draw nine kos
that indicates that he's a boxer right
that indicates that he's not a knockout
artist that indicates that he sets the
stuff up
uh because when you have
you know um more
fights then you have knockouts there's
there's a little bit of indication
um on there so you know the ratio the
percentage
of knockouts has to be a little bit
closer for you to be considered just a
knockout artist
all right so they stand in the middle of
the ring
begin the conversation on
tony
tony week said he wants a good clean
fight
don't be in there throw in the mud
oh they respectful they're respectful
all night nicely touch gloves
so all right so we got r b singer number
one versus r b singer number two
oh my god this this right here
looks pretty good
all right
so all right so you have um
love this in the southpaw stance
and you have
gone live and it's in the orthodox stand
they're both in the middle of the ring
just you know tapping jabs they just
touching each other's hands just trying
to get the feel of it while love is
trying to creep in
so you say gonzalez
gales
is uh um
it's a heavy jab this is the first time
i'm
seeing him fight to be honest with you
so he he's he's actually good straight
right hand down the pipe and he hit love
with a straight right hand
um that was decent
okay here we go
oh no they're they're
they're both southpaws my bad i do
apologize
all right so that was a straight left
down the pipe from galas all right so
they're trying not to step on each
other's toes
right now so
it's it's man
it's really just a feeling around them
jabbing jabbing jabbing in the middle
nothing too much
what's going on
get those likes up we had 39 we get the
50 i'll tell you the high guys joe
look at that jeff right hand okay
so
love threw a left hand
right straight and then spun out
okay okay he hit him with a straight
right
i mean straight left down the pipe again
he's jabbing with his right hand because
they're both south balls
so
everything is really in the middle of
the ring it's not too much happening yet
they keep tagging each other with
straight lefts
so
not too much happening right now
like i said they just um jab and perry
and jab and perry and jab and perry
in the middle of the ring not too much
stuff
it's it's a little bit boring to be
honest with you because nobody is
actually taking the
the initiative to go forward
you know love love
caught him with two straight um
lefts
right off the top of his head
and
galileo's tried to oh
he caught him with a good left that was
a drop all right so um love
leaped in and tried to take a chance i
mean not um not love gonzalez leaked in
and tried to take a chance love caught
him with a right hook right cross
and uh dropped him coming in
ended around
a couple of seconds to go
so of course
of course that that round goes to low um
it really was a fill out round until
uh gales tried to jump in
as soon as he tried to jump in
uh love hit him with the right and then
drop them
so i
it was it was off balance shot
hey king boo boo hey forte
yo
all right y'all at 40 we need 10 more
likes and i can give you the high guys
story
look at that see it it was it was a
beautiful it was a beautiful right
he caught him coming in
he went to jump in hook
on the side of his head
dropped him
it's it's it's like a check left hook uh
but it's for southpaw so it's used to
check right hand all right
so this is definitely
uh
he he's astute in his boxing and in his
poise
he got six more likes and i'm gonna tell
you the story
six more i don't know who's holding on
to those six likes but get those six
likes in there and i'm gonna tell you
the story
all right so round two started
love is starting out a little bit faster
and you have
oh
all right so uh
garlaz did the same thing
that love did to him
the same exact thing love leaped in god
last hit him with the right same thing
now but this is happening in the
beginning of the round
gales is hunting him
love is back pedaling
gales is on him
love is backpedaling he's trying to get
out of that shot
oh ho ho ho
galas is definitely chasing him down
all right so love leg don't look right
that leg don't look right oh he caught
him with the string right
i mean straight left oh
all right so right now they're boxing uh
against the ropes love is actually the
one that's being backed up gales is on
him
trying to get closer and throwing power
shots he's throwing power shots with the
straight left
uh down the pipe where
and he's keep on trying he's keeping the
pressure on love right now love spun off
the ropes and got him in the center of
the ring right now and love is uh in a
defensive posture with a pouring jab um
and he's shooting the
the left straight down the pipe trying
to get galas off of him he you got a
momentary reprieve right now
gales is turtled up
and he's in the defensive posture as
well not giving too much jabs he's just
still stalking nice and close
and
love
through two straight
uh lefts down the pipe
and hit galas on top of the head
all right so oh
a straight left i mean a straight right
down a pipe from love
uh right off the face of gales they're
in the center of the ring right now
gales is in the defensive posture and
he's uh
turtling up
again
this is a hard round to score because
early in the in the round
you gotta say gales was winning the
round he's still winning the round it's
still
uh a 10-8 round
unless there's a knock down on love's
part
then that round could be
even but here we go there's 18 seconds
left in the round
oh okay love hit him with another
straight
uh left down the pipe
love is on his bicycle moving from side
to side hoping not to get caught again
okay so
now
both okay so there's two 108 rounds one
ten eight round went to love in the
first round and the second round uh
gala's got the other 10-8 round
uh necromancer zay with the 5 super chat
hey king saturday friday night fight
really makes the weekend fun thanks for
all the great work
thank you my brother 100
we got four more likes to get the high
guys story
four more like until you get to fifty i
got you i got you
there the fight is the fight is good the
fight is decent i'm not gonna lie and
then we got the main event right after
so
um
look at that boom same exact thing he
caught him with the same thing
and his was a little bit harder that
right hand
boy he turned off the right hand quick
bow
dropped him
very quick okay
late for dinner with the 10 super fan
sticker that's what's up that's my dude
go looking out late for dinner
all right so
all right oh
so they started the um the third round
right now so both of them was warmed up
both of them is exchanging uh hard uh
left hands they're both southpaws so
they're both exchanging hard left hands
in the center ring
uh the jab is pretty much non-existent
uh because what's what's happening is
they're capitalizing off of the jab and
they're hooking off of the jab and then
the the other fighter is at the deficit
okay so right now
uh love is going underneath
with his uh left hands
and
gales is going over the top with his jab
and his right hands
and he shot a straight left down the
pipe and love got out of the way
all right so love is backing up throwing
jabs and godless is stalking him
pretty decent stuff uh pretty decent
work
in the center of the ring right now
uh love is dipping low while you have
gala is going high
so it's like pick your poison type of
thing
still again in the center of the ring
not too much
you know
so but
gales is walking him back
but he should be shooting a jet right he
should be shooting a jab as he's coming
in even if it's a pouring jab it gives
him something to worry about
and you know he's trying to get love up
against the ropes so he can do his work
but they're just circling each other
right now so uneventful round to be
honest with you love is trying to shoot
the
straight left but it's not connecting
all right now
gales started to shoot his right jab
and it did some decent work but he's not
keeping up with that position
all right so
again gales is trying to push him to the
ropes
and love is dancing moving from left to
right stepping out of the way
and back into the center of the ring
while love tries to pot shot him with a
straight left
jabs
very very
very mundane
round to be honest with you third round
could be a little bit more
um
not that much
we got 26 seconds in on the round
hopefully something can happen but
they're in the center of the ring again
you know anytime you get the the
referee's shirt with no blood on it
they're not doing too much work
11 seconds
oh we got that 53
all right so i can tell you that hi guys
all right check it out
all right so we go to packs right and
everybody's getting to the house and
everybody as soon as we get into the
house at pax everybody picks their rooms
and stuff like that right so as soon as
we come in we have an airbnb and the
airbnb guy is um he's greeting us right
so they're talking downstairs uh i had
enough i'm going upstairs fouled my
wrong upset with the living uh
conditions as far as the bad goals want
all your dragons you know the story
all right so our first day at pax that's
the next day right we come back to the
house
as we're coming to the house we're
standing outside because only one person
has the key yeah any airbnb only one
person has a key why do we have a key
what the hell is going on all right so
we get back to the house as we get back
to the house
tell me why the home the airbnb renter
the guy that rents the house
tell me he doesn't pop out
hi guys how was pax i'm like what
how was the day did you have a great
time
yo it was the creepiest thing
ever ever the creepiest thing ever okay
so you thought that was a one day thing
he did it the next day hi guys
yo that was the running joke for the
whole time that we was at pax for those
four days
hi guys so anytime you see us say hi
guys
hi guys and he pops out and he sounds
like the dude from that's not american
dad right no no that's um
a family guy he sounds like the guy
that's always after his son
that's no joke i'm dead serious
he sounds like the old dude with the dog
who dragged his legs he sounds just like
them hi guys
[Laughter]
and it was absolutely creepy i slept
with the light on i'm not playing
[Music]
yeah my six four behind slept with the
light on you best believe it the house
felt like resident evil 2 ah man i
played too many video games
round four they're in the center of the
ring um again
galas is trying to back up love
which he's successfully doing
uh love is in a defensive posture while
gal is stalking uh love is uh sticking
the jab out without throwing the
straight left behind it
it's not with purpose so gala is
stalking with purpose but right the
galax is trying to
hit him with the the the right cross to
be honest with you the right hook and
his
right hook for south paws okay so he
just called love as love spent out but
it was a glancing shot
again uh
this is this is how i figure
the next fight to be if bevel can back
up uh
uh canelo if bible can back up canelo
straight uh left hand from love right
now
that will be an interesting fight to be
honest with you
and that's that's what i'm looking for
i'm looking to see if that can happen
all right so
love is pouring at the jab
so is uh
gala's and
he's trying to
put in work he needs to work with more
experienced uh southpaws it to set
better traps you know a love is
but gala's is is a stronger he looks
like the stronger fighter
but love is landing decent left hands
on uh dallas
[Music]
very very decent stuff very good work
here
in in the middle of the ring i mean if
you're looking for a tough action fight
this is not going to fit the bill for
you those first two knock downs seem
like uh aberrations to be honest with
you but they're trying
but they're trying in a cautious manner
you understand anytime you get two south
paws together it's definitely gonna be a
style clash because they're not used to
facing south poles they're used to
facing orthodox fighters
pretty good though
i said herbert
all right all right so
we halfway through it
because i think this is a 10 round fight
i think i gotta double check
it could be a 12-round fight i don't
think love love has the belt i don't
know oh it's for the vacant belt
texan hawaii
that's the only thing different with um
the zone they get to the the main event
a little bit faster than everybody else
you know sometimes with normal
pay-per-views
you know it goes a little bit longer so
close
all right so we have round five
they're jabbing in the middle to ring
the center of the ring again
and
again this is just
it's
two cautious southpaws uh waiting for
the next one to
uh make a mistake
nice work in the middle
again um
you want to see
a lot of action and you're not going to
get a lot of action from these two
individuals you're going to get a lot of
uh posturing
you know and
little bits of hair trying to steal
around
because trust me they don't want to get
a head butt they don't want to get a
clash of heads
and and that's what they would get from
him because they're just really not used
to fighting another southpaw
feet positioning is key yeah we might
see this problem with bud versus uh
spence
uh everybody's expecting bud and spence
to
um give this hell of a performance i
think two southpaws don't give a hell of
a performance and if bud fights orthodox
he's going to get eaten alive
because the southpaw stance is the only
thing
that saves him in fights because if you
notice a lot of time when bud fights bud
goes to orthodox
and he starts to lose ground and then he
switches to southpaw to get the leg up
so
i don't know
that's that's that's an interesting one
that's an interesting one to figure out
love is moving into the center of the
ring he's being a little bit more
aggressive now but gales is um again
he's the one with the more
sharper punches and i think he hits
harder
it's just
you know love has a little bit more
skill
but i think
technically sound
you got to go with gales
i don't know nice is he he has a hip jab
so he throws a jab from his hip straight
up godzilla galas does
it's
oh man you know these are hard to score
rounds these are the rounds that you can
give to anyone
who i got tonight i'ma tell you right
before the fight who i got i know that's
a sucker move right but
like i said i gotta see i gotta i'm
looking for something
and i'm gonna give you
the the the thought process that i have
behind it
that's see
this this is
this is hard to watch because it's hard
to judge
it's hard to watch because it's hard to
judge
dragon heart yobe tv
member for 11 months that's my guy
peace love life let's go
that hey hey guys mad creepy yeah i
would have called my mommy glad you made
it back
safe and sound proud of you king ilp
is a household name baby let's go i wish
he's a household name but what we do is
we connect with our fan base our friends
our families anybody like i told dudes
when i was in pax pull up on me man come
on take a picture let's talk let's chop
it up let's talk we all play video games
right so we'll
talk let's let i don't i don't i don't
care i don't care if you don't don't
don't make the mistake thinking
oh he's an xbox dude that's that's a lie
like that's that's for fabrication don't
don't do that you know come talk to me i
talk switch i talk nintendo i talk i
talk uh playstation i'll talk pc
whatever man just just talk talk boxing
um i'm trying to learn mma
you know i need funds for that but um
again yo listen
just just
see me talk man
because again
we all we all connected we all connected
like this man
we all connected
we have one purpose right good games
that's it
all right so every time you know a
fighter gets punched in the face and he
shakes his head or he gets punched in
stomach and shakes his head like nah
that ain't hurt yes it did it hurt so
love just got punched in the face and he
goes nighting her yeah it did it hurt
so they're in the middle of the ring
right now and they're trading now i
don't hurt punches
which will be straight left hands or
looping left hands from the south pole
stance
all right so again uh
nobody is taking
that that that initiative to go forward
you know
they need to they need to push the fight
they need to go forward and i think
that's why
you know these guys are right below
right below the main guys
yeah both are really technical in the
ring that's the fact man that's what's
up ufc and fines and king yo
little known fact uh fonz and i was
supposed to do uh combat talk we were
supposed to you know um
do it because when i was doing combat
talk before i would do little snippets
and stuff and throw that up and it'd
usually be after the weigh-in because i
don't care about a fight until the
weighing i don't care about the talking
and speculation i don't care about none
of that stuff um i actually just care
about the actual fight itself
so if you're not um if they don't ever
get to the ring i don't care about the
gossip i don't care about that that's
not me
so
my stuff is after they weigh in i give
you my prediction throw it up and i'm
watching a fight
so if i'm watching a fight why not do it
live why not hang out with you guys
right now what hang up have my drinks
watch the fight talk about it with you
and have a good time why not
and i'm not a real bad drinker so it'd
be a little bit of beer a little bit
orange juice a little bit ice a little
bit of
splash
[Music]
okay
see
crowd is starting to boo
because this is exactly what they're
giving us they're giving us
boo worthy performance you
know their feet tangled up against each
other and that would happen with
southpaws
i would tell a fighter don't get caught
up in in the crowd
you know because you go ahead and get
all anxious because of the crowd that's
boring and getting that get yourself
knocked out
12 seconds left
in the fifth round
another lackluster round that's hard to
score
that you can give it to either guy to be
honest with you if i was to score if i
was
right now they're drawn to me
that's what's up
that's what's up
yeah yeah yeah i used to box
who's that who they asked me that
hustle hustler star hustle yeah i used
to buy
pretty good with them pretty good with
these little monsters pretty good one
so canelo's getting his gloves on right
now
talking about weighing in
how hard is it to lose half a pound and
now
the man got them horns how hard is it to
lose a pound
it's it's very hard if you if okay so
let's say you cut weight all that you
could right before training camp right
you can't wait right up to the part
where you're weighing in all right so
you have a skill that's inside your room
you weigh yourself before you go
downstairs you go downstairs
and then you get down there and let's
say you off by some ounces if it's a
pound forget about it forget about it if
it's a pound but if it's something
ounces you off buy some ounces they put
you in a sign of suit you hit a bike and
you go sweat it out you go they make
they make sure that you do you defecate
you know you get rid of it around seven
is up
and uh love comes out with a straight
left
so they give you enough time
to to get that weight off if it's a
pound you're just going to lose money
because that means that you had a bad
training camp you wasn't disciplined
enough um because a pound is way too
much
but ounces yeah it's very difficult
oh thank you so much phillip
my predictions is just based off of what
i see in the ring and what i expect to
happen and usually what what what
expects you know to transpire usually
transpires how i see it um
it's just taking the emotion out of it
and just seeing what's presented in
front of you to be honest with you a lot
of dudes keep their emotion they don't
keep their bet and favorites in it
and can't separate the
the fight from the game you know
i can separate those two
i'll just tell you in the beginning too
like i really like danny garcia but i
knew earl was gonna watch him
all right so
right now love is uh getting a little
bit more comfortable and he's taking a
little bit more risk but he's still
doing it while backing up
that see that left that i mean that
right hand that dropped him
scared the hell out of him so he's not
engaging in the fashion
that would win him
the fight he's engaging in a fashion
that will get him a draw and
it's sad
so here we go
we had seven rounds
all right so there we go gales uh threw
a le uh yeah that was a straight right
to the body a straight right to the top
and then came with a hooking right
and he caught love with all three of
those shots
because love was too busy backing up
but it wasn't hard shots
it was telling shots just not hard shots
love does a step in jab and it steps
right back out doesn't follow up with
anything that is necessary he needs to
you know because he's all right so he
stepped in with the jab and he threw the
straight left down the pipe but the
problem is he's not finishing it up with
the three he throws the one two no three
behind it
you know usually you gotta do at least
four four punches
if you want to win you should be
throwing at least four punches
then instead of the one two in the pot
shopping
who everybody got for the main event
i'm pretty sure everybody if you got
canelo i'll put one in the chat if you
got beverly put a two in the chat
no ones no toes
get these ones let me get these toes
all right one canelo canelo canelo
canal
[Laughter]
we ain't got no bible we got no bible
love
[Music]
ain't no love oh bible
wow
imax just threw out the one two like ah
nah
all right round eight
oh boy here we go
all right somebody wants to light a
firecracker on the galax but because
gala is coming out like somebody stole
those cookies
let's see
all right he tried to shoot the right
hand down the pipe
let's go
it's
it's a boring fight
that i gotta say that if if love is
actually winning because love if he
feathers the jab and that's like just
flicking inflating it and then shooting
the the left down the pipe
um so he feathers the jab shoots the
left
they're not doing anything in the
rig it's nothing that you can really
respect to be honest with you
it's it's it's decent but
all right so you got galas that tried to
um
walk him down with three punches
and he throws he throws the harder shots
because he threw a straight
and threw a left down the pipe
and caught love
but again love keeps trying to time him
with a shot and it's not working he
keeps trying to time him
galas is back in the center of the ring
throwing this jab
stalking him
this has got to be
this is not a good leading fight to the
main fight this is not good
matchmaker matchmaker had to match our
love better
than what he's doing right now
but let's keep going
so you got gala is just stalking him
again
love
back is uh close to the ropes
and kyle is just pushing him now let's
hit him with a
right hand
slash hook
from the jab
and he's still trying to
stalk him
right back to the corner
and galas lets him out the door again
he doesn't know how to to to
cut off the ring properly
the footwork is off
all right and love is doing the jab just
throwing them off tied them up they walk
to the center ring
back at it again
terrible jab terrible jab
24 seconds left in the ring
and around
round eight
this thing could hopefully hopefully be
over soon
and then they hold
10 seconds left
galas is stalking
love is turning
garlic seems like he's getting closer
and closer to landing something that's
important
ask the weight question because the
lightweight ufc championship belt
i took off after being half a pound
what's the most people usually
cut for matches
yo um
[Music]
it depends on if you're disciplined or
not right so a lot of dudes
some dudes will lose 20 pounds in
between fights to get to a fight some
dudes
he said i'm watching the scenery of the
front row
yeah i feel you
um
it's it's usually how disciplined you
are how much weight you got to cut see
some dudes blow up in between fights
some dudes don't like those dudes like
floyd mayweather they usually stay on
weight and then when it's time to fight
all they doing is working on the actual
skills
so
a lot of dudes blow up some dots some
dudes get so high and weight get 15 20
pounds up in weight and then the whole
camp is a weight loss camp
that's terrible on a fighter because
you're draining yourself to get down the
weight and then when you get down there
you didn't really work on anything in
camp and then you you tired you get
knocked out
so love
and uh gal is in the middle of the ring
i guess they must have told love to back
him up
because love is actually finally coming
forward now
but
gales is again the taller i think he's
the stronger fighter
and he's working he's walking um
love down
oh man this just
there we go so love throws a straight
left
but godless comes right back
i'm telling you i think goloz is a
stronger fighter and love knows it
that's why love isn't pushing the point
he feels the punches he understands
exactly what's going on so
again
love is trying but it's not exactly
uh
a good wholehearted effort
there's jabs in the middle of the ring
with occasional straight left all that
some of our friends in the ring and the
ring is none of that good one buddy none
of that stuff man i'm trying to take
your head off i'm trying to eat lunch
let's go
this is
oh man
i he had a good opportunity on a
pay-per-view card to be the second fight
to the main event to actually show
exactly what he has
all right so now he now he's stepped up
with uh
two straight left hands
but he has he has to work a little bit
harder you know
golez has to work harder one of them
somebody needs to take the initiative
take the lead in this fight
and actually become the one that wants
to win i'm looking for the championship
heart and one of these two fighters one
of them to take the reigns and actually
go forward
all right they go love love him two
times again with the straight right i
mean straight left
i'm not a good one
tapping gloves i don't care for that and
do that after a fight
under a minute left
in round number nine
mercifully
this fighter will be coming to an end
there they go bowling again i mean i'm
not the only one
eddie renoso studies she called film on
the tcl tv
that was funny
nah man
nah
if love really wants to win this fight
love is going to have to put more in it
because all he's doing is working at a
draw
all he's doing is working at a draw
[Music]
next fight is bible
versus canelo
i don't know everybody's looking at
bible like uh
bible looks scared i don't think so
buddy
that's when you learn this stuff click
the wrong things
see myself
see canelo look warm
bevel doesn't look warm worst thing you
can do is get into the rain cold
getting close to it getting close to it
a lot of these dudes is going for canelo
a lot of them
i'm getting close to my pick i just got
to see them as they coming in i got to
see the body posture and stuff like that
and then i can just tell you exactly who
blessings to everybody that's pulled up
because you could be any place in the
world but you chilling right here
shout out to
1090 jake
what he said he look
serious through no he
i don't know
okay
back into the center of the ring round
ten
has been a jab fest
poor jabs
evening rain
evening
pulling up right before the fight you
know somebody wasn't telling you to
fight by the start
all these dudes is exchanging love taps
in the middle of the ring
love is acting like he want to win okay
finally he doubles up
with that straight left come on man get
the win his face is right there for the
pickens pose
come on
yo
i've never seen two tired dudes just
stand there and throw jabs at each other
i thought they was gonna give me
something to work with so i can actually
you know
report exactly what i'm saying
i just saw
two lazy jabs
followed by a terrible left
from god okay gobblers threw two lazy
jabs and came up
with the lazy left uppercut that caught
all love
okay here we go
love is try you know what and this this
is gonna be a lesson for love
to
every time you fight you take every
fight as if it's your last and he needs
to work on setting traps because he has
no ends
like usually he's supposed to step in
fake faint
and he has none of that there
don't see it so he needs to work on that
all right
we made it to the last round
thank you all you guys that survived
that
we got to the last round this is it this
is coming up right now
and
we can get to the main event
and you already know canelo's actually
gonna put a network
little do you know so is bible
that's why you're tuning in
you want to hear
what i think
all right
i don't care if y'all know suspense long
enough
right oh
double left hand
stop playing with me king
all right
i think devil
is me i'm hearing
some popping on the mic
yeah
i told eric we have to work on that
aspect i don't know what the hell
is causing the popping
let me bring the levels down
do you still hear the popping in the mic
let me know if you still hurt hear it
when i pull it down like that
let me know
because i'm i'm working with the levels
right here
that's not true
you still hear jesus
well i gotta work on it for the next
thing um
me and addict was supposed to be working
and um
yeah
man addict was working on it
i'm sorry guys i'll i'll get it together
next time to be honest with you
i'll definitely get that pop out of that
i don't know
where the hell is it coming from to be
honest with you
and i can bring it right back but
let's bring it back up
i gotta figure it out because anytime
you hear me on the podcast
it's not there this
we're watching
the probably
one of the worst fights that you could
put on before the main event because
this puts the whole crowd to sleep
nobody's amp nobody has any energy
going into the next fight so hopefully
the next fight has everything that
you're looking for
to be honest with you
oh man
i really thought that this fight was
going to have a lot of you know spark to
it
apparently the only spark to it is my
mike
terrible terrible
whoa
for the last drink
for the main event
two drinks and done
two drinks
last drink for the main event
29 seconds
and nobody's selling out
everybody's holding their o's
left
terrible
bull i would be so mad if i was eddie
he said the mic is popping like boogaloo
shrimp
where's the best part best spot to stay
in vegas i don't know i have to ask my
man i'm supposed to be going to vegas to
[ __ ] got a couple of things that i got
to do this year so that would be my
first time going to vegas being honest
with you
no that
tastes like a spike of sunshine
that's right
oh no hell no i thought that was the
last round oh god
oh god
no
this has to be some twisted dog doctor
strange
time jim
oh hell no
stephen strange whatever he doesn't put
me in a perpetual loop all right all
right all right
he win
well he did the door marble
but it was in the house
what's going on
on my podcast so you can
bring them back to statue
video soon
all my favorite times with you in the
ninja shot so that's what's up yo yeah
yeah definitely um
just the same way that this is a live
show uh uh kos king of the statues is
gonna be a live show to be honest with
you so they all all all live shows and
what i'm doing with this is you know
it's going to be overlays and stuff like
that you're going to be able to call
them we'll be able to talk about stuff
um we're working on all these things in
the background and on the scenes uh
kos that's being finished that's going
to be
a live um
well it's gonna be a dope show where
i'm gonna get y'all more involved
in the whole aspect of the show
that's what i want i want interactivity
i want i want people connecting talking
building uh reaching out
uh you know just just like doing a
little bit more
yeah
live kos
oh palms palace was the was the best
that's what's up
i said i used to go to um atlantic city
a lot
so now my boy told me vegas is
light years is better so
definitely going me and wipe down this
[ __ ]
so first time
i'm gonna knock that out the part that's
on my bucket list too be honest
this has to be i know eddie hearn is
throwing up in his mouth because this
got to be the worst
fight that you can
before
thank you um i already i have like 10
statues upstairs and i got like four
down here right now i don't even unbox
yet so you know i was just saving it for
that i was going through a big turbulent
time
in in
in my life earlier
last year well at the end of last year
you know a lot of things changed and
stuff like that so i decided to take a
break from doing it and i was doing um
dcx on
friday nights and so that stuff yo
what's going on see mackie made it baby
[Laughter]
so um
oh okay
so uh got less is uh trying to land some
punches he's trying to win now gales is
trying to get a love out of that he has
love back in the corner and he's landing
straight left hands
so he's trying he's trying
it's whatever
sometimes is it a little bit a little
too late 10 seconds to
go if he catches uh
love with something anything can happen
but nobody is willing to sell out
it's over let's go
now to the main event
xm xm xm no problem one problem is
usually one one third i do one fall
prime one is usually one third and
usually dc statues so
i don't got rid of that dc stuff out of
my life boys
javier what's going on
paris place is fun let's go
very nice
yeah
well the palms is pretty good in
atlantic city uh so is the sands
excuse me
all right so the fight is over
we're going to the main event right now
so once these guys get out of here we
get that decision
all right so canelo out there
looking decent
but he looks like he's pushing his
punches hmm
hmm
this might be very very interesting
people
hmm
this
could be
something very very special
you never know
yeah man
it's me
it's it's me it's me that's me with the
pop
wanted a controversial one
to be honest with you
i don't know
you win the day and you watch them call
it tomorrow
it's not your phone man
yeah yeah i'll let that go oh it's not
your phone
yeah sunday gonna be fire
sit down sit there with attic we're
gonna run a stream we're gonna figure
out exactly what the hell is going on
because
this mic is definitely dope poles so it
ain't that and y'all hear me on iron
lords it's not that i think it has to be
uh
what i'm using right now i think i have
to update it and i don't want to update
it now while we're on the show so
oh
[Music]
yeah that's right you better show love
to your mamas
she don't want to got you here
you definitely don't want that issue
all right so
everybody's asking me
who i got
[Music]
canelo doesn't look
uh
as fit as i would want him to look going
into this fight against the bigger guy
devil's gonna be 190 going into this
fight canelo the most that he can get to
is probably 170
right so that's a 20 pound um
disadvantage for him
uh bibble has the longer reach and a
nice right hand
um
bible is not caleb plant
um
devil is not
a a lot of the fighters that canelo has
been fighting later lately
bill is actually dangerous
right
um devil
actually knows how to throw a straight
right hand
bevel knows how to throw a left hook
bevel
is a very very
competent fighter
right
we've all seen canelo
and we all know that he has problems
with people that can box and can move
now we're not going to confuse bible
with being a slick fighter like you know
as far as skills go
um
he's um
he's pretty much
uh a
different version of kovalev i don't
think the version of kovalev that we got
that fought um
canelo was the best version of kovalev
to to fight
it
is canelo just banking on the fact that
he'll be able to break down bible does
he think that bible will stay there the
whole night and allow him to tee off on
him
or is canelo
going to go and put in the work
you know to actually
make that happen
i expect it to go
at least eight to nine rounds right
and um i expect
if
canelo gets down on the skull cards
because he starts off slow
that bevel uh continues to maintain his
pace if bible wilts at any point in time
in the fight
canelo is going to capitalize on us
does canelo canelo will use his jab to
get in or does he
just rely on left hooks and right hands
these are questions going in that you
know i think that
canelo now
relies more on his power
than he does on his boxing skill
will that serve him tonight
or would bill will get a 12 round
decision
conventional wisdom is going to tell me
that uh canelo is going to knock him out
in the 9th 8th and 9th round
but the odds is saying
the betting odds are saying
that he beveled by decision by split
decision
is it tonight is the night that we see
canelo bad knee
show up
that's the reason why he wasn't jabbing
that much people
um
if somebody's going to take the money
and run and go with the 12-round split
decision for bible
i ain't mad at you
but boxing sense tells me canelo by
knockout
by
late ninth round
early eighth round
um
because i believe that the fight is
gonna break out probably within like the
the fifth round something like that
uh because canelo is gonna probably
either be down on the cards or the cards
are gonna be even and he wants to
separate himself
so
my my my prediction for the fight canelo
by ninth round
knockout
will i be surprised
if bible
gets a 12th round decision
split decision
hell no i won't be surprised
because canelo's body weight his body
mass
um
indicated that
he wasn't all the way there
so
i honestly think that um
i hope this was like a a tactic i hope
it was a tactic to get the bet nods
to swing in bible's favor i hope
one day canal was physical
yeah yeah
yeah
but maybe it is the day that canelo
actually
that catches up to canelo this this
could be tonight
people don't understand that like
and
the boxing ability
weighs heavy
prediction is cannot low 50 split
decision 50 unanimous decision so you're
figuring that it's going to go to a
decision regardless to what right
yeah
one day he might be
the smaller fighter by too much
by by an inch
so
if is is it today that that inch matters
because at some point time that inch
gotta matter right at some point in time
these these stats just wait this
distance this stuff has to matter
right at some point in time you're going
to have a big little man versus uh um i
mean a big a good big man versus a good
little man
and in that ratio you always pick the
big good man
you know i don't um
that's fighting today i can't say it's
canelo because a lot of he
didn't fight charles he didn't fight
benavidez he did fight a couple of
people that i felt that can actually
push him or take that l from uh give him
that l he didn't fight on draw days he
didn't fight a lot of dudes um
so
i i don't really
uh no
at what point in time does his does his
tank run out does his tank run out
tonight against bill that would be a
shame because
that means that he could actually risk
greatness against some of the greater
fighters
middleweight super middleweight guys
that he has that's in his proximity that
he didn't waste that those that l on so
i hope he doesn't
but
bibble is young
bible is strong
bible i've seen him rock like once or
twice
but
if bible can get loose in the fight you
never know
he said canelo was a cheetah
yeah
he said it was the meat though he had
the meat and the meat had the stuff
inside i don't know
i wasn't there feeding them the
meatballs
they
could be
but um
canelo looks relaxed
canelo looks warmed up that's a big
factor going in
i don't think we should be shocked
yeah yeah bibble always has power
throughout the whole fight
you say you sick versus canelo alvarez
you're out of your mind
use
music is a monster
yeah he's known he's known to do that yo
mac i love the fact that you know
exactly what what what we're talking
about here
and uh and on god i honestly believe
that uh
this this this could be tonight
does does does bible have the eye of the
tiger does he have
that that that
killer instinct that that kobe bryant in
him does he have that michael jordan in
them does he have that the uh lebron
james that willingness to be great that
allen iverson
does he have the sugar ray leonard
it's it's it's a individual that wants
to
be the best
and go for that greatness
we already know canelo has it
you know um we already know when when
when that that bell goes
canelo is going to give 110
he he only lost to the
the greatest fight ever
the hell with what anybody else says
numbers wise and and
and record wise
floyd is the best
um
but uh
and he beat a young canelo when canelo
was in his prime so
again you know what else do you want the
man to do so
is tonight the night i don't know it
could be could possibly be
i give bible a hell of a shot
there's so strong match versus
yeah
let me see
he said canelo versus
gonna happen it's not gonna happen
no his his knee is
canelo knee isn't healthier he can know
listen i just saw a video with him and
his knee with ice and all this other
stuff
he probably got a meniscus tear and he
probably got surgery done on it and that
stuff lasts for about so long i had a
meniscus tear in my knee
and um
over a period of time your knee starts
to bother you so
who's sick versus fury
um they're not going to fight fear just
retire
that's it
you're not you're not going to see that
fight
that fight is not happening so um you're
going to see deontay wild the fight for
the wbc belt
and um
he's gonna i forgot who he's gonna fight
uh for that belt
out of walden
he's gonna fight for that belt
um
please so
you'll probably uh have uh us versus uh
wilder
and that's that's a fight that uh wilder
can actually uh
actually win
because i don't think too many people
can stand up to wilder's punch
be honest with you i thought fury was
probably one of the only ones that could
actually stand up to this punch canelo
never really had fast feet
he he get lazy to cut off the ring
you come forward pressure and he applies
he just really doesn't go backwards yeah
this yeah yo this is that is so true
it never really mattered really too much
because he was never pushed back it only
mattered
when he fought uh triple g and triple g
had him
moving from side to side basically
opposed to just moving directly forward
directly back
in that fight he actually
showed some form of boxing skill
you know uh for his eyes so
right now there's this thing in the
mexican national anthem
and then uh we're gonna get over to the
main event
so
after the american
national anthem
yeah wilder has
ungodly power
if you look at both of those fights that
he had with tyson fury
he knocked fury down
he's he
how many people can you say hurt fury
but every time wilder landed cleanly
yes
that's exactly what he did
the only one person that was able to
beat uh wilder
because he has the ultimate separator
the mexican style of fighting is not
just to apply pressure
the best person i saw
doing that style
so-called style was julio cesar chavez
senior
definitely not junior
julio cesar chavez would work behind a
jab
a beautiful right hand and the body work
was impeccable but he had very subtle
decent head movement and what uh julio
cesar chavez would do is
and juan marquez does this too
um
they cut off the ring
so it's just not idle pressure that they
put on you they put pressure on you
while they're hitting
your shoulders your hips
your elbows
you know um busting your guard
everywhere they touch was meant to
actually
injure so
the mexican style of boxing isn't just
applying pressure is applying smart
pressure while cutting off the ring
right and by while staying in the pocket
and slipping punches
oh well you know you you feel like uh
fury won all three fights
i say this had they actually count that
they're knocked down properly
that's a he he was out
but see this is the this is the thing
with that
if
they count that knockdown in the first
fight
where fury rolls from the dead and i
told you to check his blood
um
we would have never got the other two
fights
because i don't think
ever in this world
deonte would afford him again
so it took him to have to lose in order
to get the second fight and for whatever
happened in the second fight for him to
push for the third fight for us to get
the third fight but no if deontay wins
the first fight
never happens
it's probably more technical than fury
but fury
is the bigger
stronger
fighter
he has boxing ability
so right now bibbles coming out
devil
nothing nothing no fuss no muss just
very no flash
don't get confused by his face by like
he looks like like a kid that that
doesn't know what's going on
he's at this level he's the champion
don't ever forget that part
he has something to tell
slower
why doesn't canelo fight the athletic
brothers with power you talking about
the canelo brothers
the charlo i mean the charlo brothers
um
he wouldn't fight jamel he will fight
the jamal jamal is the middleweight
champion so jamal is the one that he's
not fighting no he was offered 45
million a fight that he didn't fight
okay so
he said all fury have to do is lean on
who's thinking it's over
yeah
he put that big body on him
you never know
stuff happens
here goes bebo
wow
i know people ain't born
they're gonna be here for surprise
tonight
he's gonna be a whole lot decent a whole
a little bit better
than the last fighters
that uh canelo fought a little bit
better
i always said that this fight was a very
dangerous fight for canelo
and i didn't exp i didn't really expect
him to take this fight but he is
all right so his game face starts to
come on now as he walked out the tunnel
and you know listen everybody's going
everybody got their favorites everybody
got who they want to win
nobody wanted buster douglas to win
until he did
nobody thought he van the holy shield
was gonna do that what he did
you know
a lot of times
stuff happens that people don't want to
happen that does happen remember montel
griffin
versus roy jones jr
i'm just saying man things happen or
james tony voices roy jones
super fight
music has more eye pleasing style and
fury
you can't get the head taken off by the
wilder too yeah that's crazy
louis ortiz
king kong
doesn't have the chin that you think he
has
and anybody who has a suspect chin that
walks in the ring a while that they
bound to go to
yeah
roy jones made amends the second fight
really quick knocked him out he didn't
take him with the game
but remember montel took he got hit
while he's down on the floor
and just laid down on the floor
that's what's funny
yeah andrade would beat him but he's
never gonna fight him
[Music]
i i think
at first i don't think canelo's pound
for pound
the i don't think he's the powerful
pound king
um
and i know somebody asked me who do i
think is powerful though king i would
just say aerosmith's
that's it
in my opinion
um
coming back fighting top notch
he's ever since he got the belt it's
just been top-notch competition forward
who's not the face of boxing
tell me jay who's not the face of oxen
yeah
ortiz does have a bunch of training in
this chat anytime he gets flushed
down goes ortiz
that's what canola has
that heart
that ability
gotta be smart with it
what's my favorite history of boxing
yeah it'd be powerful pound when he beat
crawford
he's gonna demolish profit
it's not gonna be as close as people
think
my opinion
i think i think he's just going to be
too big for him he's going to sting
wrong
he breaks people
[Music]
now they doing this thing again
come on man
he's doing too much
hey
listen i used to watch princeton i see
my med
yeah
boy oh boy
he used to do a lot too
[Music]
oh my god i guess you got to do this
right you got the money do it
[Music]
he said canelo's a money maker that's
all he is
a cheater and a punk
crazy
you crazy jay
here he comes he comes out to sparks and
yo listen
you eddie hearn is pulling out all the
stops stroking canelo's ego to the point
that canelo's not going to want to go
fight on anybody else's network
he's on a raised platform
if you do all this and you get knocked
out what if you do
okay
what if he does all this and and and
gribble is just like i can't stand you
and i'm and bible put in that work and
knock them out cold
yeah but
did make come every time that and how
mad had brutal
hands yeah like floyd
excuse me
princess i seen my men had really bad
hands
[Music]
yeah spencer's power profound demise
yo so okay so they put canelo on the
stand
raised them up
just to shoot fireworks
all this other stuff right and took them
down and they played
it
oh my god
oh my god
so he's coming out now
and they have uh the mexican um
women
well i've ever seen them is that
quinceanera
with the dresses like doing the flowy
dances so
um
i'm gonna tell you this
this is the most animated that i've seen
canelo coming to the ring
usually he just come to the ring and
just walk
yeah he would be a meme
yeah ryan garcia has a future
and i think um
he did himself a disservice by leaving
eddie renoso's boxing camp
but i guess the pressure that canelo's
putting on was too high somebody just
can't deal with pressure
so
i i don't think he's ready for tank and
i don't think he's ready for devin haney
and i think he knows that
and at this point in his professional
career ryan garcia he
he hasn't
went to where he's supposed to go
to achieve what he needs to achieve
and and that means he he hasn't
perfected his boxing ground i would love
for his trainer
instead of his manager to be oscar
because i thought that he mimicked oscar
in so many ways early on
yeah there's too many killers in this
division
there's too many there's too many
killers in his division his division is
definitely
stacked with individuals that um
they king just
decimate him
all right so
bevel eyes always look like he got beat
up already
not new nothing
but this is what we came here for
all right so
we know by looking at this this the
fight card all the money went to canelo
because they really didn't have too much
of a bottom undercard to be honest with
you
i can't i can't honestly say
the same for tank endeavour though
somebody's
should have been had a zero taken away
yeah they should have but i don't know
yeah who doesn't look like a russian hit
man
baby face assassin
see mac you crazy as hell boy
all right so
well as you're looking at them right now
bibble looks a little dry to be honest
for me bubble looks a little dry
right and um
canelo we already know
because i told you he came out
oh man russell maura i wouldn't have
went with hispanic ref
just just to keep the stuff out of it
you know to be honest with you
that's just my opinion of it
i would have went with like 20 weeks to
somebody
[Music]
he's real animated he really wants to
see this fight
this is the most animated i've seen this
announcer ever
so his joint is the fight starts now
that's that
that's crazy well it's a packed house
and it's good to see because i was
watching fights that didn't have any
crowds and with the covert thing and
it was truly scary
let me see
give me kenny bayless hell yeah
help yeah
all right so bible is 19-0 with 11
knockouts
that's a very tight record
canelo's trying to get him while he's
green
and
that could be a mistake it could be it
could be fruitful because remember
um
floyd
got canelo when he was green
green meaning
you're not all the way matured yet as a
fighter
right
so
see this is what i'm talking about
internal look at his body his body looks
off canola's body looks soft is does he
is he a little bit more fluid this
evening a lot less tight
maybe
yeah yeah yeah bevel has a high chance
to beat canelo this evening
we definitely gonna find out in the
first round to be honest with you what
are we working with
[Music]
so you said the full division world
champion
the flags is flying
dudes is ready
so 11 50 at night we didn't break the
barrier
did we get this over within 10 minutes
and everybody get to say happy mother's
day today mama
i don't know
we will see
[Music]
there we go
all right so both fighters have been
introduced both fighters have uh
gotten everything so they're in the
middle of the ring right now
canelo is not giving any eye contact
he's standing on the side building was
squared up looking at him referee forces
them to touch gloves to go to the corner
all right guys let's get ready to go
let's get ready to rumble let's do this
you know was praying on his knees
stretching out his arms
[Music]
all right so bevel should be right now
tonight 190.
all
right this is it right here right so all
you can hello fans
this might be a situation
all right
so pivo bible comes out
shooting a jab
canelo's turtled up
and
that's it right there so
so i figured it's just a jab
and canelo uh does a one two
and hits his guard
so yeah see that's the difference right
there canelo actually would take the
opportunity to um go after bible
and he's trying
bible keeps the high guard up while he
shoots the jab i told you he has an open
guard so he's keeping his hand to his
face
as he jabs so both of the fighters is
orthodox devil hands is really loose he
just threw three punches and threw a
right
canelo threw a left hook that moved
bibble back close to the ropes pivots
back in the center to the ring high
guard again shooting the jab canelo is
doing a peekaboo style
high peekaboo hands on the forehead as
he puts his jab out
this was touching his guard
tapping them giving him something to
worry about
so
canelo is landing uh straight right on
levels guard
devil continues to
poke at
canelo's guard again canelo keeps his
high guard up
bevel
keeps that right hand
glued to the side of his face
so yeah it's just still in the center of
the ring
um
bevel is doing a lot more work
with the jab canelo tries to shoot the
straight
uh left
down the pipe
i mean straight right down the pipe
and he does it again
and uh bevel spins off the ropes
jabs throws a one two three
spins i told you bibble can actually
throw punches in combination so that's
what makes them a lot different than the
last fighters that canelo has been
fighting
so but the one thing i tell you is
biblica's knees
and i think that's going to be at his
detriment
because if canelo can catch him with his
knees locked but that left to the body
that he just threw right now that canelo
did
the rule just threw four punches five
punches
six punches unanswered
and he's stepping back you have 20
seconds left in the round
as um
devil's trying to keep his back off the
ropes and every time he's in the center
of the ring he gives canelo three four
shots all right so canelo heard the bell
and canel was trying to do work to steal
around
all right you know try to hit after the
break but it didn't work
pretty decent round um
first round i got to give the bevel i
thought bill did the most work
um
he said
if bible
is roughing him up every time he comes
close yeah
um
honestly i think like i said i think
bill won the first round
um
could it could you have scored it for
canelo
quite possibly but i think bill did most
work [ __ ] mike tyson and his wife
beautiful
mike tyson is a fan of boxing and that's
great to see you know that's great to
see all right so bible is at the center
of the ring already before the round two
starts and bible is back on his jab
again remember he is the champion canelo
has
to come take the belt from the champion
so bibble is pumping these jabs out
there
and you know they're hitting the guard
but they're still giving canelo
something to worry about but i told you
canelo if canelo can jab his weight in
and canelo started jabbing
all right so bibbles trying to to keep
canelo out can i was trying to get in
and canelo knows how to break and cut
distance very good
one two and he's trying to step in
back in the center of the ring
it will tap some
jabs he's not just throwing one two jabs
people
bible is throwing three four jabs and he
shoots the straight right hand down the
pipe he has to get respect from canelo
very good very good canelo
steps in
throws the uppercut in
and he's back to jab and jabbing
left hook
from canelo
doesn't land little goes right back to
the jab and throws a one two three
and bevel is throwing a one two three
four
uh canelo went to the body
they hit each other's heads and the
referee told them watch the heads
canelo's hitting uh bibble on his
shoulders
and bible
is throwing the one two
down the pipe pushing canelo back
back into the center ring
and uh
bill is again right there canelo throws
a looping
right hand that pushes a bibble over and
he tries to connect with the left to the
body that misses right hand over the top
from canelo levels against the rope
right hand to the body from canelo
bible spins off goes right back to the
jab
and he throws a right hand three four
five six seven uh bibble is unloading
his shots now
um and he's showing that he's a
combination puncher
all right
canelo is uh again dipping trying to get
close inland power shots while bibble is
pushing them back throwing rights and
lefts
and bible well
this is a lot of work that canelo is
taking to land his shots and
now he's throwing his shots
canelo and bibble spins off the rope you
know has a left to the body
all right to the body and he's in the
center of the ring bill turns
uh and shoots his jab right back at
canelo
back to the stick
you have uh 10 seconds in a round
and
time
all right so there bible put in the most
work canelo had the more pushing shots
like he shots that hit you that'll push
you back
um
canelo did a lot of good bodywork left
right to the body
um
i got to give that round again to bible
so it's two rounds to none
i can't look at mike tyson the same
after seeing him celebrating like a kid
on christmas after wilder lost the fury
yeah bill does know how to keep distance
well you know it was a it was a huge
history thing between mike tyson and
deontay wilder uh deontay wilder
threatened a lot of records of mike
tyson's and you know
that was a beautiful right hand between
the guard that canelo
hit
bevel with but bibble comes right back
and lands four to five different shots
canelo's loose very limber
round three starts
and bevel is again is across the ring
meeting canelo
and cutting the distance and going right
back to the jab
all right so now canelo is trying to
slip the jab
bible is still hitting with canelo with
four or five different shots
all right
so canelo is going to the body with the
left hook
and bibble is going right back to the
jab canelo's throwing the right hand
canelo is throwing an uppercut trying to
get bible against the rope left hook to
the body canelo was doing bill was
throwing one two three four
he knocked his mouthpiece out his mouth
i
think okay no he didn't canelo still has
his mouthpiece in his mouth
um he was just looking over to the left
all right canelo is going to the body
to the head uppercuts left
left to the body left to the head
and bibbles back to his jab in the
middle of the ring
center of the ring work here
is uh given to bible bible's pushing
canelo back with one twos
and canelo is throwing
uh the straight right hand to push uh
bibble back
and
the the jab fight is being won by bible
bible is actually keeping control in
distance
but uh canelo is pushing him back to the
ropes this is where canelo does his best
work
with a straight looping uh right hands
oh
devil caught canelo
with a left hook leaning in
um
bevel through a one two canelo doesn't
look stable here
all right left hook from canelo to back
bevel off
um
canelo
is a
stalking number bibble is throwing three
four five combinations
all right and canelo threw a
straight right
and an uppercut but he's hitting bibble
on his shoulder trying to stop the jab
hand
but bevels continued to throw a 1-2
very decent work from bible bevel
continues to pump the jab canelo is
throwing while looping shots
and
he's jabbing his way in
going to the left to the body
all right so bevel again
throwing the one two he has canelo
against the ropes
he's throwing the one two three he steps
off canelo
and he goes right back into jabbing
canelo to the body
very smart and he tried to
capitalize on a left hook uh we can mill
up against the rope canelo's in the
corner
the referee's about to stop it the round
ends
that round is definitely given to bibble
because the position that he had canelo
in at the end of that round was
definitely detrimental to canelo i think
canelo tonight needs to be able to slip
that jab and work his body more
efficiently instead of separate little
left hooks that he's throwing
hmm
yes let me see
awesome play by play thank you so much
um okay so what bevel is doing he's not
throwing all the angles of manny
pacquiao because manny pacquiao has a
bunch of lateral movement from side to
side what bible is doing is what he's
doing is he's throwing everything down
the pipe right but what he's doing is
he's elevating his shot so he doesn't
throw the jab in the same place he
throws a jab top top and then he'll move
it down to mid mid just to get contact
and then he'll shoot her right behind it
to give that hard distance and come with
a left like he's doing right here so if
you notice that the jab it will hit at
different varying heights in order to
keep canelo distracted now canelo needs
to work his jab in order to get to
bible's body that's what he's doing
right now so he goes back to the high
guard and he uses the jab to step in the
slide behind teaches you this day one in
boxing bible is back on his jab and he's
stepping back throwing the jab
but they're both in high guard now
canelo has bevel up against the ropes
bible spins off the ropes throws a right
hand uh canelo's back to his jab high
guard right hand they're both javelin
bibble will not give up the jab fight
devil is using this to his advantage to
jab two three jabs canelo's sidesteps
goes to his left
very good fight so far
uh bible and canelo both have on high
guard canelo is not jabbing anymore
bibble has won that small contest there
and he's back to the jab now he's going
up and he's going down he's throwing
left and he's throwing right he's
hitting canelo with four or five
different shots canelo is eating four or
five different shots to land one shot he
swung for a left for the body and missed
he's got a build up against the rope
shoots a right hand a looping right hand
over the top hit guard and head another
looping right hand
hit bibble on the side of his head back
to the jab canelo opens his guard up
again he goes back to the right hands
and bibbles against the rope bible spins
off the rope back into the center of the
ring high guard canelo again lands
another right hand over the top
uh back to a jab bible high guard jab
jabs abs out
and
he's uh he's keeping that right hand
close to home because he doesn't want to
get hit by the left hook
that's what he's keeping that right hand
close to home for
and uh bibbles back to the jab one two
three
all right so he has canelo up against
the ropes he's landing shots one two
three back to the body
one two three
back to the jab canelo's back is against
the ropes bible right hand keeps sliding
because he keeps trying to hit canelo on
the body with it i will loop it around
his hair
right straight right hand
bibble has canelo up against the ropes
and canelo is not doing anything he's
looking for a break in the punches
in order to catch bible
bibles pushing
pushing canelo's back is still up
against the rose bibble continues with
the jab
back to the center canelo's off from the
center
in the ring his bible with her right
hand now
canelo has bible against the ropes
i think
canelo is trying to break bible's
shoulder
um
that left hook was blocked
by bible
canelo hit him with a nice uppercut from
against the ropes canelo throws a right
hand
bibble has a high god on his right side
gotta give that round to canelo i think
canelo had the more telling shots in
that round even though beverly did good
work i gotta say canelo did the best in
that round with the right hands and he
had the uppercuts i don't know why they
taking so long to get his chair out i
think he's having a problem with his leg
because he doesn't sit down immediately
inside the chair
when the chair comes anyway canelo won
that round by the right hands and
uppercuts he's throwing looping right
hand shots around bibble's guard to hit
him in the air and then he did it the
last round when he went around the guard
and then he automatically shot it up the
middle like ala mike tyson see jab jab
and then looping
oh there goes the uppercut beautiful
uppercut
beautiful uppercut beautiful uppercut
that's right he pinned his hands up
against his guard and shot the uppercut
through his guard
it still got through it's definitely
good
all right so here we go they're back in
the center of the ring
round five
this round this fight is definitely uh
living up to its billing
bib will stand in this ground
but canelo is starting to come on now i
told you a fight will break out in round
five and we are in round five so this is
where the tesla wills comes in and who
has the most so canelo right now is
freestyling a little bit because he's
throwing his jab and he's starting to
feel a little bit comfortable
bevel has to take that comfortability
away from canelo
all right so
very good fundamentals by canelo canelo
is sliding on bibble devil goes right
back to the jab right back to his uh
fainting
and canelo doesn't fall for the thing
canelo is back in the middle of the ring
high guard and he goes to the
floyd patterson cross arm um style
[Music]
and he goes right back to high guard
all right and
now bible throws the one two
canelo throws the left hook pushes
bubble back
hits guard
canelo is back with bible against the
ropes he went back to the uppercut it
wasn't there
left hook to the arms of bible
bible to the jab
to the jab
right in the center of the ring down
canelo high guard sent to the ring i
noticed any time in the center of the
ring canelo goes high guard
all right and he pulls him out all right
devil land four shots on canelo he has
cannot be against the ropes he's teeing
off on canelo right now
canelo waves him in say come on bibble
says no get back to the center of the
ring
[Applause]
bible show his most success right there
but canelo was unfazed by anything and
waved him into fight now canelo is
swinging back at uh bibble chasing
bibble back
bevel back then was just spinning
this is the most boxing ability i've
seen from bible bibles like i said he
has an open guard style he has a
low jab
but he puts his arms up soon as canelo
gets close
all right
so now double jabbing and
bible is dancing around the ring trying
to wear canelo out
all right he goes right back to jab and
canelo
head stomach varying levels of the jab
very very very decent round canelo shot
a right hand over the top
pretty good level good on the jab center
the ring
uh we've got 20 seconds to go
bevel is moving from side to side giving
canelo a lot of issues and he is landing
four or five different shots
this has got to be
bible's best round of the fight so far
that has got to be bill's best round of
the fight so far so far given four to
one uh in favor of bible
ring looks slightly larger than what
canelo is used to more movement
is going to lower the gas tank legs
would get heavy earlier around canelo
canelo is heavy and look tight i told
you
when i saw them canelo didn't look like
he was in that shape
and um eternal should i i i i try to
explain he didn't look like that for
cobalt for kovalov he looked like he
came in incredible shape
bevel right now is out working him with
the jabs up and down
excuse me
and the right hands were definitely
ridiculous
um one two three six so this segment
right here they're showing right hand
left hook
right hand left hook right hand
left hook
right hand
left hook canelo ate every last one of
those shots except for the left hook he
turned his head away he ate every last
one of those shots
all right here we go again
so they back in the middle of the ring
round six
canelo is definitely putting the mustard
on the punches now but bibble is landing
his jab and stepping back canelo is uh
tripling his jab and throwing a right
hand right after to give vivo against
the rope and he's trying to stalk him up
against the ropes
bibbles back in the center ring he turns
over and he lands a one two three that
one two was crazy he hit canelo hard and
flush he keeps hitting canelo very flush
with these right hands and i don't think
that's gonna bold well for canelo canelo
got bill up against the ropes he throws
a left and a right he throws a one two
and another one two bill spins out back
into the center of the ring
bible's not throwing anything right now
bill was just moving canelo throws the
uppercut right hand bubble blocks all of
that back into the center ring back to
jabbing
back to jabbing so canelo high guards
into the ring back to jabbing
all right
bible is back to jabbing hooking
all right dad he tried to throw the
right hand canelo try to time his right
hand with a left hook that would have
been marvelous
all right but bibble is uh stabbing him
to the body with the jab he's stepping
back he's making canelo work for
everything
everything
all right so
here we go canelo just uh threw a right
hand
and he threw in another right hand oh
left hook from bible off of the catching
pitch bubbles back in the middle of the
ring
um
i don't know
canelo looks like he doesn't have the
gas this night
all right so a bible stepping in now
uh
one minute left in the in a round and
bible is walking canelo down he has
canelo up against the ropes
uh he's stalking him he has a low jab
he's throwing shoulders showing him
shoulder
and he's uh just jabbing just trying to
think them and bait him in
he's throwing the jab jab and
he keeps on waiting for bible to throw
the right hand bill is playing
throwing the jab
and canelo is a backup against the ropes
throws four five six jabs
right hand left hook what a quart canelo
again straight right hand
one two straight right hand he backs off
for canelo canelo comes back in tries to
catch bevel bible goes right back to the
jab and he has canelo up against the
ropes again 10 seconds in the round
bible lands the one two
all right bible lands on one two
billboard has a jab canelo's back up
against rope does nothing round is over
again i got to give that round the bevel
if we did the most pivotal work in that
round from that last minute on bevel it
was like all bevel
uh up until that one and two uh minutes
it was give and take but that last
minute bible put in the work for the
last minute
he said bible's about to get robbed
blind
he said watch and observe production
now's canelo
just sitting back
waiting for the counter punch this is
true
devil must fight extra hard to beat
canelo facts
this is this is this is eyebrow uh
lifting stuff right here um i told you
guys before the fight that bible
definitely
has that ability and it all depended on
how canelo trained for this fight what
was going on
canelo's face is marked up red eddie
renault so
canelo walked out of that corner with a
purpose he looked like the terminator he
comes out with a left hook comes out
with a right hand bibbles back on his um
on his bicycle moving and jabbing moving
and jabbing in the center of the ring
right now so canelo's not going into the
shell he's eyes a one two
oh man
bibble catches him coming in with a one
two canelo's backing up against the
ropes uh
bibbles jabbing one two three
uh he's throwing jabs and that jab is
working overtime fellas i'm telling you
right now bible understood the
assignment and he's going out there for
it
one two one two
canola throws a left hook but it's not
to no avail
one two from bibble one
he's throwing a jab the whole time
the whole time oh left hook short left
hook check your left hook right there
right hand check left hook right hand
oh man
bible's putting the beautiful work in
the middle of the ring this is something
to behold people
this is what i told you this is what
happens when you cherry pick and you
don't fight the canelo um the charlos
and the benavitas
all right bible uh is working him one
two three four
all right so he has canelo up against
the rope he lands four shots on canelo
one two three four again he has canelo
across the eye
all right canelo uh comes off the ropes
throws the one two
three throws a right hand to push bevel
back canola looks like he's laboring
while he's working because canelo uh
bible goes right back to the bicycle
right back to defensive mode
canelo's just hitting shoulders and arms
as bevel is working again now back to
the center of the ring one two three
bibble
all right so
all right left hook right hand from
canelo
canelo's coming over the top
all right there we go
bevel hit him with a one two canelo
canelo walk to the side um double
jabbing right hand left hook
all right
the devil's turning them
bevels up against the ropes and he
fights off the ropes he tricked canelo
he thought canelo thought he was going
to turtle up and bibble fought off the
ropes uh with a one two three and spun
off canelo try to throw uppercut bibble
hits him with a left hook behind the air
spins off
all right canelo goes to the body
a left right to the body
bibbles backwards against the rose and
every time canelo hits and lands bible
fights off the ropes gets back to the
center of the ring he throws a jab you
got 20 seconds left in the round
all right left foot quick left hook from
canelo quick right hand from canelo
they're both blocked bibble back in the
center of the ring
10 seconds
left and bevel is chasing him and he
hold he caught the cor canelo with the
right hand
right before the bell again another
round for bible this is outstanding work
and canelo's eyes is ready looks like he
stepped into a lion cage this is
something terrible for canelo right now
canelo need to pull out all stops and be
the champion that we know that he is he
is not sitting down he is uh drinking
water standing up i think his legs is
locking up
telling you
and now he's sitting down anytime you're
supposed to fight who you're supposed to
fight fight those people and get those
fights out of the way
see we can accept the loss from
charlotte we can accept the loss from
benavidez right now this was right here
the bevel oh
boy
sorry lemon can't talk to you baby love
you to death baby
canelo won the title weight class that's
what's up boom
short left hook right hand over the top
left hook if that left hook would have
landed canelo would have probably got
dropped tonight oh man bibb was back in
the middle of the ring can those open
canelo has a world-class chin people
that shots that he landed all right so
canelo's coming out right now
canelo tried to land a head butt
hey now
all right left hand right hand
jab jab left hand
bevels out here working
billboards out here working
jabs up top oh my god right hands to the
body oh my god bill did a one two three
oh man they must have told bill to go
out there and finish this work uh-huh
canelo landed a left hook stopped all
that crap
canelo's throwing the jab and left hook
trying to throw that right hand
trying to throw that right hand left
[ __ ] on the shoulders of bibble
see this is the difference a lot of
times the way it goes left hook's
landing not landing right now he throws
a right hand to bible bible still has
that high god he's turning off the ropes
and he cooked canelo with a quick one
too left hook one two
one two three four five
one two three four he got canelo up
against the rope canelo's looking tired
bibbles throwing the left right hand
oh man
canelo's throwing a sick jab that jab
didn't work right canelo's back is up
against the rope he looking tired the
bible is standing in front of him
looking energized looking like he see
food he went for it he threw a left hook
he went for it but he missed he missed
everything folks
i'ma tell you right now canelo looked at
him like floyd looked at him no way
brother not gonna land the day jab jab
jab straight right hands
a bible is on canelo canelo looks like a
wounded tiger
oh man bibble can you finish your food
are you gonna play with your food today
all right so live jab bible is not going
for the bait canelo tries to swing him
off and oh bibble slides in and hits him
with a right hand big
canelo's looking tired
bibbles pushing him back bevel's back uh
canelo's back is up against the ropes
canelo throws a jab to get outside the
ring he throws a right hand to the
bible's body to back him up he throws a
one two the bibble catches bibble with a
one two now bevel back is close to the
ropes
and
bibble side steps one two canelo cuts
him off throws a right hand bibble
throws a one two anytime canelo wants to
take a breath he doesn't he pushes
canelo down to his knees canelo is tired
canelo is tired
[Music]
all right so they're back in the center
the ring the action is back together
canelo tries to throw a right hand then
we'll go straight to his body then
brings the left uppercut to his head
referee came in and stopped the action
for some reason i have no idea
round is over bevel again
bible putting in that work to make it
hurt baby
it's looking sick out here boy
looking like you walked into a horror
film canelo
the streets have spoken
um
i honestly believe
it's hurting canelo the the the role
work
stuff is hurting canelo
because when he can't hurt his opponent
he can't get his opponent out of there
and he hasn't he
yeah
let's just see mack i'm i'm telling you
i've seen the same things
um oh liberty i'm i'm telling you
he hasn't landed double uh double
punches yet i mean double digit all
right canelo is coming out giving it his
all but you notice all the punches is
landing
on um
devil's gloves
and bibble is back to pushing the jab
all right so now bibbles did the one two
he's going back back to the one two this
is an actual fight that canelo is in
right now
all right then we just did a slick
uppercut in the break canelo's guard
then on the side of the ropes all right
back to the center of the ring canelo
takes a step back uh bill goes back to
high guard but there's a flexible guard
canelo swung for uppercut and mess did a
right hand over the shoulder uh
bibble on the shoulder he's back to a
sloppy jab
bibbles back in the middle he has a lot
of nervous movement
all right so you're moving from side to
side giving a lot of angles to canelo
not throwing a shot just getting them
tired
he stabbed him to the stomach with a jab
canelo throws a double uh jab right hand
off the guard a bevel bevel steps to his
left does nothing just keeps feigning
keeps fainting
and he wants canelo to get tired canelo
doesn't see what he's doing high guard
bible's coming in for the kill bible's
throwing one two three he's throwing
every shot is another shot he's throwing
one two three
he has canelo in the corner he's
throwing three punches one two three
he's right back to canelo's body he's
going to canelo's head he's pushing
canelo up against the ropes
all right canelo's off the ropes then
the center of the ring canelo throws the
jab to back bevel up and he throws the
uppercut to the body
nice nice nice left uppercut to the body
uh canelo's hitting bible on his
shoulders and straight right down the
middle he's trying to throw it up
because bevel is pinned up against the
ropes for the first time this is the
first time canelo was able to actually
do some work he's throwing right hands
he's trying people left hooks he's
throwing the right hand he caught bigger
with that right hand level's back in the
center to the ring back to the jab high
guard canelo can't get that left to the
body like he wanted can i will throw a
one two he's taking a laboring deep
breath he backs up off of devil bibbles
tries to get him back to the ropes
the center of the ring left hook to the
body from canelo
bible stands there high guard both high
guard watching right hand from canelo
right hand from canelo left hook from
bible then we'll caught and shot the
left hook
uh right hand from canelo
one two from canelo left up right hand
from bibble
uh huh the difference left hook from
bevel uh-hum bible high guard he's
catching his shooting he's stalking
canelo now so canelo tried to throw a
left hook i mean uppercut bubble through
the left hook right hand
jab from bibble
end of the round um i got to give that
round to canelo canelo did the most work
that round i think bible was setting
stuff up but just didn't wasn't able to
capitalize
kingdom
yeah
yeah
bevel is pressuring uh canelo this this
this whole fight that that round right
there he was putting mental pressure on
top of canelo but canelo was actually
doing the work so the round will go to
uh canelo uh but bible actually got more
pressure work on them while taking a
rest
so that's how you taking the rest um
at the same time while keeping pressure
on you know you faint a lot to give
somebody something to think about then
you just stab them to the body here and
there throw one to keep them keep them
understanding that you're in this fight
canelo's up i think that gave canelo a
little bit of spark of thought
all right so bible meets him back in the
center to the ring now
okay so
all right canelo goes oh yeah right hand
left hook to the body here we go
left hook all right bibble back to the
jab back to the jab oh nice uppercut
from bibble all right bill back to the
jab right hand left hook uh-hum bible
thrown three four five shots there we go
again back to devil throwing more shots
canelo with a right hand bubble with a
stiff jab that quick canelo off guard
uh
canelo throws a right hand i mean a left
hook that catches bubble on the right
side of his head
all right a bit with a left hook
jab jab left hook right hand straight to
canelo's body
all right if he wants to stop canelo
he's gonna have to go to canelo's body
all right
back to the center of the ring
all right canelo throws a jab
jab bibbles back to his jab canelo's
back to his jab janelle keeps putting
his hands down whenever possible bibble
throws a one two and catches canelo
going backwards
all right canelo tries to throw a jab
bibble blocks it
two jabs from uh bible
bible stands in the center of the ring
bill throws the jab
jab jab
all right so now it's getting more tight
it's getting more technical
because right now bevel understands what
he has to do when canelo knows what he
can't do
right now
so
bill is throwing the jab has canelo up
against the rope canelo is moving
sliding in and out of the way making
sure that he doesn't get hit bevel is
throwing little shots here and there
uh-huh testing canelo testing canelo to
see which way he's gonna go and canelo
wants to catch billboard with a counter
but bill's not giving canelo the
opportunity he's just keeping him in the
corner putting the pressure on him
all right oh and he catches canelo with
a right hand canelo threw a left foot
but canelo got caught with a right hand
from bibble
all right so they're both setting each
other up one minute left in the round
bible's back in the center of the ring
throws one two three canelo steps back
half a step back then comes right back
in tries to land the left to the body
doesn't work bible tries to take his
head over the left hook and goes right
back to jabbing
right back to jabba he's giving him an
up jab so he has to worry about the up
and the mid level of the jab one two
three bubble is walking on him now
all right he has canelo back in the
corner he throws the right hand he's
pushing canelo back with these shots
every shot he lands he pushes canelo
back you know comes right back with two
jabs pushes uh bibble back to the center
of the ring we have 20 seconds left in
the round
we have bevel uh dancing in the center
to the ring low jab
jab hand
canelo uh tries to jump in canelo
and bibble both trade shots in the
center of the ring bible hits him with a
right hand ended around round the bevel
again
what bible is doing is actually applying
pressure without applying too many hits
and that is keeping canelo stagnant
canelo is not throwing punches because
he's too busy playing defense trying to
figure out what bill was going to throw
next because he's trying to counter the
shot and it's not actually working out
for canelo in this fashion
well you know canelo still staying
limber he i don't know maybe something
is tightening up on him i know we'll
know more about it later
but right now
see canelo tries to go to the body but
again bill throws three shots
every time
hollywood rules damn this kid has no
fear i told you before he looked like he
had fear going in
not at all not at all
all right so now we are in the 11th
round championship round canelo meets
him in the center of the ring
throws a 1-2
bevel high guard back up against the
ropes he spins off the ropes goes right
back to the center of the ring with a
nice jab
canelo is throwing everything one two
left to the body
right to the head
but he's still not breaking the guard
all right he's trying everything
he's trying everything
left to the body uppercut
left hook
right right hand
and
devil's throwing one two three four
bevels backing them up with strong shots
he's working that jab
all right so he's throwing a one two
down canelo's pipe canola backed him up
with a three jab and right hand
oh bevel throws a one two three
backs kinda low off them canelo punches
aren't hitting with the same ferocity
that they normally hit with
and we're at a point right now where
devil is actually out working canelo
and
here we go again devil is throwing a 1-2
in the middle of the ring
jab to the top and he's shooting the
right to the body
he's going to catch canelo leaning
because canelo is worrying about the
left the right to the body he just
caught him with the right to the top of
the head
canelo doesn't have any snap on his
punches and bill does
all right so they're in the center of
the ring right now
and um canelo is going to the left of
the body it's not moving bibble at all
all right so
bible is right there bibble quick
catches canelo with a left hook
um
i think canelo is out on his feet he
catches canelo with a one two canelo
picks him up and he's gonna throw him
frustration a bible grabs him in a
chokehold chokes him in the neck
not today satan not today
breaks them up they're back in the
center of the ring
uh both uh button heads together
canelo throws a jab bible throws a jab
right hand left hook jab
left foot dibble is on him trying to
knock him out
all right bible has canelo up against a
rope and he goes for it again
one two
jabbing him into the chest
right hand
grabs him by the neck holds them doesn't
allow canelo to do anything
referee is being too much now
there was throwing the jab they're back
in the center the ring canelo throws the
left hook to the body right hand to the
shoulder
all right right hand to the shoulder
tries to go for uppercut can bibble goes
for the one two canelo goes for the one
two sent to the ring both guard
10 seconds left in the round bubble
catches them with a left hook
and it's into the ring canelo throws a
jab
and the round is over
that round is bevels again we're at a
point right now where canelo has to get
a knockout we're going in the 12th in
the final round this is the championship
rounds canelo has to show their
championship medal if he wants to get
this belt from bible i told you going in
bible got that boxing skill it depends
on what was going on with canelo to be
honest with you obviously we understand
what was going on told you he didn't
look right in the beginning of the fight
but
again we gotta let it play out we gotta
let it play out
canelo's losing by points yeah
yeah he wasn't gonna allow canelo to
flip him over
he had too much weight for canelo
yeah he's tired i told you he didn't
look like he came into shape to begin
with
so we're watching history we're watching
good fights right now and this is the
good fight right here we go last round
canelo comes out throws a left hook
right hand in the
in the center to the ring
he don't go back with the jab
jack with the back with the jab
back with the jab
and he's throwing the left [ __ ] throw
right hand to bible
bible steps back
canelo still throwing the left foot
canelo's canelo throwing the jab bill
was throwing the jab
canelo tried to go to the body but was
stepped out the way bevel goes to the
body his canelo canelo was coming back
hip it was with a right to the body or
left foot to the side of the head
canelo's actually coming out here ready
to work
left hook right hand
right hand right hand
he has bible up against the ropes
um canelo does they're doing
head-to-head uh
bevel fights off the ropes
he throws a left hand right hand left
hand right hand jab left hand right hand
right hand left hand he call canelo he's
working canelo he caught canelo with a
left foot this man canelo has one hell
of a chin oh my god i'm gonna tell you
right now people canelo has one hell of
a chin and he fights before back oh my
god that was one series of punches
canelo's right back in the mix throws a
left hook throws a right hand
canelo has bevel up against the ropes
canelo's pushing bibble back bibbles
coming right back at him jab in the
middle of the ring one two
uh one two bible
this is what it is
canelo slides in with the left hook
dibble right hand jab
bibble jab jab
jab beautiful jab jab snapped his head
back
oh jab snapped his head back jab caught
canelo when he wasn't
noticing oh man canelo
the bible is working him coming in left
up is the left hook is the one two three
is the one two three that the one that
you'll see just how you finish them one
two three that's how you don't you know
those on his toes backing up throwing
the one two beautiful canelo come on
come on there we go one two double steps
back in with a one two beautiful canelo
back is up against ropes he looks tired
folks he looks like a tired champ
but bibble is on him
oh
hook to the body
from uh canelo right hand to the side of
the head of bible bible pushes him back
in the center of the ring nice right
hand from canelo
nice uppercut from canelo all blocked
though all blocked though
uh-huh bibbles back in the center of the
ring bible throws the left hook right
hand
double jabbing
uh-huh
pivot
is right there he tried he tried canelo
tried
i'm going to get the 12th round canelo
i'm gonna give the 12th round canelo
even though these dudes fought they hard
out this is one hell of a fight i'm
gonna tell you right now i basically got
the fight um
uh at least i got to give at least you
know three rounds i got to get all these
three rounds nine rounds to three but
the judge is going to see it probably a
whole lot closer
so you're probably going to have it like
uh
seven rounds five probably
told you man um
oh boy oh boy didn't look uh really good
at the weigh-in
um my wife ain't gonna be shot because i
told her i said that he looked kind of
soft there it looked like a knife he was
he was down for the pickings um
i'm gonna have to drink one of these
in memory boy tonight man
cinco de mayo weekend
bible look like he about to go to the
club man people clean this yes sir
bill clean as hell boy
double facing the clinton canelo look
like he he ran down the wrong alley boy
nah canelo ain't gonna rob nothing man
not tonight not the night satan
not the night
scene yeah he know
you know he know what it smell like the
last time he smelled that smell floyd
was standing in the other side
boy but this boy did him worse than
floyd floyd floyd did some nasty stuff
to him
thank you brother thank you brother
this isn't about to take some tequila
shots better on that there's a fact
though
that's just a good champion you know
what you know what i like i like i like
i like
i like when
you can win or you can lose like a
champion
i like i like when you can show your
respect as a champion you don't run out
the ring you stand there man you take
the heat you get pay a hell of a lot of
money so they want to hear from you so
you give that respect right then and
then
i love this i love that
i love what a true champion is a true
champion is measured by how you win and
how you lose
[Music]
identically
[Music]
undefeated canelo if y'all bet somebody
you lost your cash you lost your cash
hey now
hey guys
bible just won
hey guys
yo i want to thank everybody for hanging
out with
king david a combat talk with the king
the professional fan
yo
i'm gonna tell you right now ain't
nobody gonna give you play by play by
like me nobody's gonna tell you exactly
how they move and why they're moving
what's going on like me but i love each
and every last one of you people that
came out and hung out with me
oh man this yo it is so dope it is
absolutely so dope it was too much way
for canelo but you know this is what
happens when you have people in your
weight classes that you should fight
you go up there you fight this dude man
come on man
and if you bet for bible
go get your dough
go get your dough
yo man
yo thank you guys for definitely uh
hanging out i'm gonna give you all this
right before we go
because this this this means a lot
[Music]
talk haters in love but it come back
salt if you really want it in the ring
god gone send a contract i'll knock his
contacts out you will feel mice trying
to take a life but ain't no competition
in the ring decipher cause i'm spitting
venom and i'm swinging fire talking
pickled peppers make them pay the piper
cause i might go live like a rude
discussion and deflate your chest like a
fool production you'll be talking like
you want a new concussion to do the
custom attitude adjustment
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve for another
knuckle sandwich i will serve heaven's
tipping moving like a tire swerve out
here acting bad thank you michael
jackson even got his one and only homie
captain you a phony homie now you owe me
action have him sinking tony tony tony
braxton and they all want to talk for
attention but the fame only lasts for an
instant mama got hands so i'm ready for
the tension i'ma leave him red you could
dance to redemption
[Music]